Gundrota: First I'd like
to announce that we are--
have part two of
the Android Developer Challenge
being announced today.
The details are located
at that url.
We will take submissions
for the contest in August,
judging will occur
through the fall,
and we'll announce our winners
at the end of fall.
This time we've learned a few
things from American Idol,
and so we will have user votes
as part of the judging,
and we think this contest
is going to be really,
really exciting.
Number two,
I'd like to announce
that we're going to give away--
to every conference
attendee today,
all 4,000 of you, this box,
which contains a link
to the SDK documentation...
[laughter]
And a few more surprises...
including an Android phone.
[cheers and applause]
This...
I think,
you know, we realized
that you could
go download the SDK,
you could use the emulator,
but nothing beats
having a real device.
And I've always wanted
an Oprah moment,
so for you, and you, and you.
[applause]
There's one more thing.
This is an unlocked device
that'll be available.
In addition,
we went one step further.
Included in every device
will be a SIM that gives you
unlimited 3G data
and thousands of hours
of calls for 30 days.
And so we realized
some of you don't have a SIM
to get started tonight,
you might have a CDMA phone,
but we think this is a nice way
to get started on you
exploring the platform.
[cheers and applause]
It's our
small way of saying
thank you for supporting
our conference as well.
I'd like to conclude
by just making
a few more quick announcements.
If you thought
that surprise was fun,
we have another
surprise for you.
Please don't miss
tomorrow's keynote.
Tomorrow's keynote, I think,
will surprise many of you
with some exciting things
that have not yet leaked,
and we're so excited about that.
[laughter]
So you'll enjoy that.
Number two,
picking up your device--
you can pick up your device
starting this afternoon
throughout
the entire conference.
So you don't have to go rush.
You don't have to go
queue up in line right now.
Go to your sessions,
and in the afternoon
at the registration area,
we'll start giving out
all 4,000-plus devices.
And we'll continue that
through the party tonight.
So don't miss
the after hours party.
We're going to have
some great DJs.
Like last year, we're
going to have a lot of fun.
And, of course, many Googlers
will be there
to interact with you.
So once again, thank you
for attending the keynote,
enjoy the conference,
and thank you
for supporting Google I/O.
[cheers and applause]
recorded male voice:
Welcome to Google I/O.